but take a look at this story let's
let's actually we're not we're live
people
yeah it happens the dnc had to disable
the chat room after trolls crash
warren appearance at native american
caucus meeting
there is so much wrong with this
headline
elizabeth warren was put on the native
american caucus for the dnc
i'm kind of i'm i'm there there are
there is a dna test
yeah she did it she released the dna
test and the number was she was half
uh one one thousand twenty fourth okay
there you go and
it just doesn't matter right it doesn't
matter
i can't believe they did this so so i i
highlight this
not because we need to rehash everything
they did
they had to disable the chatroom but the
dnc has been digital and that i think
they've made so many mistakes
they didn't realize everyone's going to
come and rag on them was going to give
them thumbs down and and relentlessly
attack them
and somehow they're
like like you were saying they were bum
they're bumbling around like like morons
slipping on banana peels yeah yeah
they put elizabeth warren on the native
american caucus panel
what that's such a slap in the face
they've already complained about this
the native american community has
already said
this is ridiculous we have tons of
thoroughly vetted actual native
americans
this is this is a mockery and then for
them to just ignore that and carry on
it's like wow
you guys really care about my name yeah
so this this brings us back to the
diabolical or just dumb
yeah i don't know they're intentionally
forgetful at least diabolical or dumb
that's like it's like a whole sequence
that's a whole segment this one's got to
be dumb
this one's got to be dumb no but but
listen listen
no it's got to be diabolical because
they all have seen the freaking test
and and it was a meme like listen i i
when i was recording this i i'm
on my main channel over at
youtube.comtimcast i
my main segment was on the failures of
the dnc because last night was
the night before last was insanely bad
with that weird you said that dancing
thing the guy did
what are they doing awful i've yeah it's
just like hi
freshman high school talent show
production just really bad it looked
like those old youtube videos
then last night we have they put they
put elizabeth warren the native american
caucus
and i'm thinking to myself how could
this be an accident
how could this be an accident it's not
it's not an accident
the funny thing is is it they're
basically like just boomerang all over
this thing
they're like they're like hey we're
gonna have a chat we're in a chat room
right right right right right that's not
gonna go well
and i think i saw uh matt tybee a former
rolling stone guy i think
uh he called it i tweeted it out he
called it a uh
a neocon telephone yeah which is
basically what it felt like
and i only took a peek in a couple of
times you know because
you got to see what's going on but it is
as bad as you think it would be
then it's actually worse and i think
this actually gives the republicans a
little leg up
what not to do right right yeah it's
pretty obvious what not to do don't do
this
it's terrible it's terrible and all the
polls are closing now
they're all tightening up right as they
keep coming out yeah
trump's trailing biden by about one
point in a bunch of battleground states
according to cnn yeah
and that's margin of error territory
yeah cnn showed like a ten point closure
or nine point closure over the last
month wow yeah cnn did
because when when biden shows his face
it's bad
news and i think uh harris
harris has something to do with that as
well oh man what a what a disaster
so you know particularly i wanted to
highlight this for one because
the dnc is just an insane disaster i
have to question whether it's on purpose
or not like they're trying to lose
i think but i do think it's a good way
to to dive back into
for people who might not be familiar
with you you wrote the book
on leaving the democratic party the og
like
you're the first person to explore this
leaving the democratic party
writing a book about it asking people
why they did it yeah so when i look at
this stuff i have to ask
is it kind of like this is you know
contributing factor uh you know the
the bumbling boomer-ism is something
that i can laugh i can laugh at right
now
but you know honestly the the reasons
for leaving the democrats just run so
much deeper
they run so much deeper and and i wrote
the book in in the aftermath of 2016.
so it's almost four years old now right
and and everything every trend
every concept that we identified in
there from intersectionality to the
network warfare to the social media
lack of cohesion uh to you know
political correctness which is really
like a version of mind control
all these things that we that i outlined
in depth in depth there
uh have just continued to worsen and it
continued to come on display
i wrote that book sort of thinking it
was niche back then even though nine
million people
nine million people voted for obama and
then for trump
but you know the attention on it was
niche but now all the issues there
they are the issues at this point
anti-globalism bring home the troops
you know let's focus on onshoring
manufacturing back to the united states
china is actually a threat oh my god
like they're trying to steal from us and
eat our lunch and poison us all the same
time
and and just also a real big focus in
the book on on college campus culture
title
ix intersectionality and i came up this
way i went all through pennsylvania
interviewed people in south and south
source central pennsylvania and up in
the lehigh valley as well
and uh did a national survey so it's
like filled with
actual data actual research actual
interviews plus
a lot of personal stories in there too
and uh
you know i don't see anything having
changed from that
all the factors that led to 9 million
people ditching the democrats and voting
for trump
they've all those trends have only
worsened i don't know very many people
who made the switch who are like i'm fed
up with trump forget about i'm going
back to the democrats now i don't think
that that's a real phenomenon
but as we have seen the democrats are
continuing to lose what people
might call the center yeah uh you know
when when you're losing guys like the
weinsteins and you're losing
you know the the reuben was a little bit
late on the game you know when when some
of our most favorite
uh formerly progressive uh journalist
youtube stars
also are leaving the leaving the left it
is a it is a trend
that the thinking i think it's a
thinking man's decision there's a real
component to the trump network uh that
is an uh very intellectual very well
thought
out well-considered forward thinking
attached to the grand conversations of
our lifetime and of
of of humankind really and looking to
extend those in our
american experiment and we see what's
happening to the democrats
the 2020 democrats as being you know
contrary 100
to the american project and and we have
to fight against that
it is literally 2016 over again the same
projections are coming out
it's the same same strategy it's the
same the only thing that's different
is that biden is a worse candidate than
than clinton and kamala and kamala
harris is
even less likely he's even less likable
seriously right
and trump has been president for four
years and is the incumbent so like
if if everything is the same except for
those elements i don't see how
how trump loses and man if the popular
polls are tightening
this early right at this point of the
election
where uh i think i saw cernovich mention
that they're
they're they're they must know it's
coming in in a bad way
if they're if they're starting to
reflect reality this early
in the season donald trump bought
the most expensive ad space in digital
yeah you heard the story of the youtube
the youtube page homepage banner this is
this is you know multi-billion views per
month
and the new york times said he was able
to do it because the democrats didn't
buy their ad space during their own
convention
i can't believe that during their own
convention where they're
publishing on youtube they didn't buy
their own ad space
i might you know i was reading the story
and i was like if donald trump buys this
during their convention how does how is
that possible
they must not have bought and i read it
and like there it is they must know
they're gonna lose
so so like i was saying earlier you know
you got biden harris
you're you're you're at home your friend
hits you up and says yo we're going out
you're in a rush your socks are dirty so
you just grab two random out of the
drawer one's all
ratty and one's like a weird you know
sock you don't care because you're not
trying to impress anybody
dairy queen so that's what it feels like
it does it feels like when i
would go out of the house with
flip-flops and socks yes
that's exactly what it's like you know
when i'm when uh
you know i get all dressed up for work
i'm sure you do when i'm when i'm
walking down the street to like drop
something mailbox
it's flip-flops it's shorts i'm wearing
i i slept in this dirty shirt it's
stretched out and sweaty and i don't
care
that's what it feels like that is what
it feels like and i i saw a report i'm
not exactly 100 sure if it's accurate
but
it was in the mainstream media that uh
obama
despite amassing enormous amounts of
post-presidential wealth
has not donated a single penny to the
biden
campaign and uh if i remember his uh his
endorsement of him was tepid and it was
i think only
after it was clear that he was gonna
become the winner yeah um
obama has a mansion in the toniest part
of washington dc that is literally
walking distance to the white house okay
he didn't get out of town he stayed
there he's worth gazillions of dollars
and he's a relatively young man you
don't think he's sitting around there
trying to
you know you don't think he's pushing
all this i think that he among
um over everybody may know how
incompetent and bumbling
joe biden is the the report came out
from politico and several other outlets
that he said joe biden
joe doesn't have it he doesn't you know
and my favorite was
don't underestimate joe's ability to
have things up
spicy so at the dnc
they actually played one of these like
it was a cringy b
tier you know dollar store knockoff walk
away of former trump voters now voting
democrat
yeah and it just felt plastic and fake
yeah i know i don't i don't believe it
yeah i don't because every time you know
i talk to
i have a lot of friends who are still
just not paying attention and they're
definitely
you know voting for joe biden but i have
some friends who
man i'm on f i was i was on facebook
earlier and these two guys that i know
from back in my hometown
were arguing and one dude was was
was just giving these really dumb meme
talking points about orange man bad
and the other dude who's just a guy a
family guy was saying all these things
about china
and about intersectional and i was like
this guy knows what he's talking about
i was like wow to see like dudes from my
hometown being
i don't i guess you call red pilled
whatever they're they they know what's
going on they're paying attention
they've been they've been politically
activated
arguing with these other guys who are
just dead set on being in the tribe
of the democrats so so that's it it's
the tribes now
so here's what i'm thinking with your
book you found nine million people
aren't i'm sorry there were nine billion
people you found many of you you talked
to them you wrote this book about it
i have to imagine the number is going to
be bigger this time around right it has
to be
it has to have to write a follow-up
there i am going to write a follow-up
the thing is i don't know how it's going
to end yet so right right so like
it's prepared in fact i've got like 10
books that i could write really
but there will be a follow-up to this of
course seeing how
things shake out but i just uh i have
not heard one credible argument from
somebody who did
vote for obama and then for trump who
thinks that was a bad decision and i
want to return
biden is just as hillary was literally
obama part three
and they're not hiding it it's not even
a
secret so we have the same choice again
and even this time even more so when
they bring people like kasich
and and uh colin powell and other
you know repub republicans uh to to the
dnc
uh it only just shows that the
democratic party is actually the
part of the uniparty which is actually
who part of the gop establishment is as
well
and so if you want an alternative from
the uniparty
there's only one person to choose i
posted a meme
a few years ago and it's uh the stock
image of
a guy and a girl and the guy's got his
arm around the girl
but then his other hand is behind it's
like
she's got his arm around him and his
hand is going behind the couch and
holding the hand of another woman yeah
yeah
yeah right so the meme is like the
democrats say all these really nice
things to you and really
it the uniparty it's it's the
establishment yeah this is why i think
it's
it's weird that so many of the
progressives have
joined in the rock throwing with the
democratic establishment
because the never trump republicans
establishment ran
you know tails between their legs to the
democratic establishment saying help
help we've been kicked out of our house
and then the progressives hating trump
said we'll throw rocks with you
and my things like if trump wins another
four years
and actually succeeds in crushing the
establishment then the progressives have
have a clean shot at 2024. i think
that's what they're thinking anyway
so are they going to vote for trump too
well
staying home sort of sort of the same
thing
if they were died in the wool and had
ordinarily voted democrat
um you know the the this theory bet you
know
sort of raises the question who do they
have on the bench that would have been
the person
you know if they were serious let's say
who would have been the person that they
would have run this year
and now i've said all along you don't
want to lose to donald trump that will
ruin your credibility right so i think
the democrats
yeah it sounds like they might be
throwing it there's a number of reasons
why you would feel like it
but that theory also then includes like
okay well who is their secret weapon
and i don't know michelle obama i mean
that's my first thought
you know it it seems to make sense um
you know we're not conspiracy theorists
we're conspiracy analysts right
i like that uh i just read that
somewhere that's not my quote
yeah and uh and and so you know in order
to round that theory out
i would try to figure out who that
person is in the background maybe we
don't know who it is just yet
but i i can't think that this is any
this biden
i'm going to keep calling her kamala
harris
ticket is is is like their best shot at
a winning coalition
i think it's their worst shot yeah i
think it it really feels like
they sat down in a room and said we
don't want we don't even want to waste
buddha judge
you know he's a small town mayor but
he's got
more than biden does so if we're
planning to lose
what's the bottom of the barrel that we
don't care well you know i mean harris
dropped out of the
i mean who knows why she dropped out
maybe she dropped out of the
the the primary because she knew she was
going to be the beep
all that time ago but also she was
performing very poorly
right right so they just added like the
worst performer to the ticket so what's
what sense is that based on her identity
yeah which isn't even the one that they
said they were gonna pick
what they said yeah so my first thought
when they picked kamala was like
it's over it's done this is great this
is the perfect person they could have
chosen to make sure that trump gets
elected again
yeah and i don't know if that was their
plan but the more i thought about it the
more i was like
maybe maybe 2024 is where it's at and
they're just
resigned and i don't even know if
they're thinking that far ahead though
because in my experience people tend to
not think that far ahead
diabolical or dumb exactly that's a good
question
you should write another book diabolical
yeah it is that's that's
and and you could do that now and then
you can write democrat democratic
deplorable
you know part two part two it's coming
it's a phenomenon so the democratic
deplorable book isn't just stories about
people i mean it is a philosophical
moral justification for why voting for
donald trump was essential
okay it's about defending reality
basically it's about defending western
civilization basically it's about
defending the enlightenment and rational
thinking
and natural rights of man that span all
epochs of history there are universal
rights that are part of the
grand ongoing human conversations that
are being completely thrown to the side
and destroyed by the democrats so
there's real reasons to do that
uh and so the these are structural
forces at work tectonic plates
they're not going to stop they're not
going to turn on a dime it's going to
keep going and grinding
and we're just waiting for that
earthquake really yeah and donald trump
wasn't even just that he was
he was a weapon that was launched by the
the you know
the sort of insurgent network uh but uh
the earthquake hasn't happened yet
because we're all still
sort of moving in this same tense
lockstep
thing uh feeding off each other with no
clear winner and no clear
new direction you know what i'm finding
fascinating right now
we had this in 2018 you had the squad
the rise of the squad you know so you've
got in omar and presley alexander
ocasio-cortez and rashida toled
most of the progressives did poorly in
the democratic primaries
uh or in in their actual yeah in their
primaries i think it was
out of 78 seven actually won and they
got
endless press coverage aoc the new
celebrity she was the
she was the one she got 8.3 million
followers
but right now we're seeing a ton of
republican primaries
with new kind of populist pro-trump
candidates winning
a lot of republicans retiring so byron
donald's for instance
if you're familiar so i think he's in in
florida's uh uh
19th okay he's a pro-trump black
conservative they tried to someone tried
pulling this illegal stunt where they
sent out fake tax did you see this
no oh i heard about it but yeah faked
text messages got sent out saying he
dropped out of the race on the day of
the election
and that's a dirty trick he ended up
winning his primary but it's a it's an
r plus 13 district which means he's in a
pro-trump
right member of congress thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8 pm if you want to
catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see
you all in the next episode
you